[Music]
well uh one thing i wanted to ask you
about is i think you made a movie that
whatever people think about you or your
where you're coming at it from is
valuable that's what i believe genuinely
however the
temporary alliance between gender
critical feminists and right-wing
conservatives like you uh was always
going to be temporary and it now seems
to be falling apart uh you know you had
a
spat on twitter with jk rowling and
others uh what do you make of the
backlash uh against the movie and
against you from that side of the of the
debate
yeah i think it's so it was an alliance
that lasted about 45 seconds it would
seem
uh which i guess was predictable i you
know tim i i it's on i find it
unfortunate it's not it's not what i
wanted i mean i
i've said from the very beginning even
before the movie came out that
uh which is one of the reasons why i've
been very vocally been supportive of jk
rowling and said many times that i
really respect the way that she stood up
against the mob
um at great personal cost and and and
stan she stands to gain nothing
personally from it and yet she has i
respected that i still do um and even if
you have a billion dollars in the bank
it still takes guts to do it and so she
does it
so that's my that's my view i have a lot
of respect for anyone who stands up
against these people and stands for
truth and if you're willing to do that
on this subject which is so so important
and i think in so many ways like it this
is a civilizational crisis we're dealing
with
and so i if if you're on the right side
of this then i can join forces with you
for this fight
and then we can get back to you know
tearing each other apart after after
we're done with this that's that's how i
look at it
um and i think when the movie first came
out there was it seemed to me anyway
among some of these gender critical
feminists
there was like this internal
fight among them about what do we do do
we do do we link arms with this guy or
what and
maybe for a brief moment in time it's it
seemed like maybe they would but then
ultimately i think they just decided
they they can't do it i think that um
one of the criticisms they made matt was
that you didn't include any of them in
the moment
yeah and that's honestly it's just not
it's it's nonsense first of all there
aren't in the movie right right
a couple things
even if it was true that i just decided
i'm going to exclude them well who cares
is this about you or i mean is this
about what do you care about here do you
care about the issue or do you care
about yourselves like it would never if
if if a feminist if jk rowling did this
documentary
it wouldn't even occur to me to say well
why wasn't i in it
it just seems like such a petty arrogant
complaint okay so who said i should be
in it you made the film you made it the
way you wanted to make it it's important
that you did it well and that's what
matters so i would champion the film for
that reason so i find the complaint to
begin with ridiculous it's also just not
true we actually did reach out to
um
a number of the so-called gender
critical feminists maybe not as many as
they wish we had i also i'm not i don't
live in the uk i'm not plugged in with
feminist circles so there are there are
some of these women that reached out to
me since the movie came out and said why
don't you contact me i didn't know you
existed before you just reached out to
me i'm sorry uh but uh we did reach out
to a number of people do you mind if i
could just
i
i've decided not to
for their own sake i'm not i don't want
to i don't want to throw anybody under
the bus because i don't the the truth is
for some of these names and there are
some big names okay
um i don't really know why they turned
us down so i think if i name them and
then oh so they turned you down
yeah they just didn't work out and so
but but if i name them and it sounds
like i'm claiming that they refuse to
because they don't want to work with me
or they were scared i don't know if
that's true maybe it just was a
scheduling problem
all i can say is that for a fact we did
reach out and the women that we reach
out to know who they are okay
and the other criticism that was made uh
was that you
you don't act i mean i've heard some
people say this it's not my opinion but
it's an opinion that some feminists hold
it actually you don't care particularly
about women's rights this isn't where
you're coming at it from
you're just someone who's using this
issue to advance your evil conservative
agenda
uh what do you make of that
i guess that's true if my evil
conservative agenda is just to preserve
truth and and reality like that's that's
what i care about uh i make no bones
about the fact that
i see some of these issues as i care
about some of these issues because
they're a battleground for the overall
war for truth so um
women's sports for example
do i care deeply about women's sports
itself do i wake up every day saying i
i'm really concerned about women's
women's sports no i don't watch women's
sports i don't care about it
you know in in general
but
it has become a battleground for the war
for truth so um when i'm being told that
a man should be able to compete against
women and be accepted as a woman
i'm saying no i don't accept that that's
insane
but what motivates me is not my
unabiding love for women's sports in
particular it's just my it's my love for
truth
and justice and fairness it's also not
fair like even if i don't watch women
swimming
it's really not fair to these women who
are having their opportunity stolen from
them
[Music]